diese entdeckung ist wirklich mehr als
mysteriös denn die nun aufgespürte
monster galaxie ist nicht nur gigantisch
groß sondern bildet auch eine enorme
menge an neuen sternen und die firma 4
milliarden lichtjahre entfernte galaxie
gibt noch mehr rätsel auf und viele ihre
eigenschaften sind einfach nicht mit den
gängigen modellen der evolution von
galaxien zu erklären alle spannenden und
prognosen facts zu dem kosmischen
monster jetzt bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen schon im jahr 2007
war die galaxie namens kosmos arzt tag
11 entdeckt worden allerdings existieren
bislang nur sehr unscharf wird bilder
des himmels objektes es ist halt sehr
weit entfernt jetzt aber gibt es neue
aufnahmen die mit den teleskopen des
atacama large millimeter array alma
entstanden sind und diese zeigen die
äußerst mysteriösen eigenschaften des
kosmischen monsters mehr als eindeutig
pro jahr entstehen in ihr beispielsweise
1000 mal mehr sterne als in der
milchstraße dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher
kenny kita duckie wir fanden heraus dass
die sternentstehung in zwei großen
gaswolken stattfindet die mehrere
tausend lichtjahre vom zentrum entfernt
sind in den meisten fernen galaxien mit
heftiger sternentstehung bilden sich die
sterne aber im zentrum dazu kommt eine
weitere kuriosität die 12 4 milliarden
lichtjahre entfernte galaxie besitzt
drei kerne um die schlingen sich eine
reihe von spiralarmen äußerst
ungewöhnlich bei unserer milchstraße
erstreckt sich die scheibe um einen
einzelnen kern von dem auch die
spiralarme ausgeben bei der monster
galaxie sind es stattdessen wie gesagt
drei kerne alle sind jeweils von eigenen
stern reichen glasscheiben umgeben
doch wie ist diese gigantische galaxie
entstanden möglicherweise durch die
verschmelzung mehrerer sterneninsel das
würde dann auch erklären warum die
enthaltenen gaswolken so instabil sind
denn wenn galaxien zusammenstoßen wird
das gas in kleine gebiete
zusammengepresst das wiederum lässt sich
schwerkraft stark ansteigen was dann
nicht nur den kollaps der gaswolken
bedeutet sondern auch die zündung neuer
stern
aktuell jedoch sei keine verschmelzung
zu beobachten so das forschungsteam
dennoch hoffen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler mit hilfe von alma
ähnliche galaxien beobachten zu können
denn damit ließe sich dann langfristig
die beziehung zwischen monster galaxien
und galaxien verschmelzungen erforschen
nach analyse des forschungsteams ist das
jetzt entdeckte kosmische monster wohl
in der ersten milliarde jahre nach dem
urknall entstanden der ja vor 13,8
milliarden jahren stattfand umso
ungewöhnlicher dass die galaxie zitat
eine massereiche und geordnete
glasscheibe besitzt die regulär rotiert
so die studienautoren denn der großteil
der galaxien im frühen universum sind
strukturlos und klein
demnach hätte das autorenteam nach
eigenen angaben eher eine art kosmischen
trümmerhaufen erwartet doch das
forschungsteam hat auch eine erklärung
für die merkwürdigen charakteristika der
monster galaxie die rasante sternen
bildung beispielsweise wird durch die
gravitation erklärt dan materie wird
durch die schwerkraft der galaxien nach
innen gezogen
diese anziehungskraft kann durch die
andere kraft die nach außen gerichtet
ist nicht kompensiert werden
die gaswolken fallen in sich zusammen
denn sie sind instabil und verdichten
sich so entstehen die keimzellen neuer
sonnen dichte materie klumpen dennoch
bleiben einige rätsel offen denn die
gängigen modelle der evolution von
galaxien erklären weder die starke
sternentstehung noch die gigantische
ausdehnung auch die mysteriöse drei
kernstruktur ist noch ein ungelöstes
rätsel ja und wenn er zu den weiteren
forschung zur monster galaxie und zu
allen anderen themen kein video mehr
verpassen wollt dann habe ich gleich am
ende des videos einen trick für euch
jetzt aber unser hochgestecktes ziel
keine werbung mehr auf clixoom wir haben
ja schon angefangen immer mehr videos
sind werbefrei
dank eurer hilfe immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor einem video ab also macht mit werdet
mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken oder auf den link in der
video beschreibung ihr bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos live streams und
noch ein paar weitere privilegien für
einen kleinen beitrag und jetzt der
trick wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann hättet mich bei whatsapp nur da
bekommt ihr das aktuelle video deutlich
vor allen anderen von mir persönlich auf
ihr handy
einfach hier draufklicken und darunter
geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
mit dem video spektakuläre entdeckung
galaxie ohne dunkle materie bis dann
bleibt